I'm gonna [ __ ] this [ __ ] up I already
know today we're gonna be guessing
famous black movie clothes I am nervous
I don't want to get along I would like
to keep my black card I think I at least
be decent but I hope to do they don't
think I'm gonna do well at all
I'm one of those black girls that's like
yeah I'm black but by default like I'm a
military kid I grew up in Asia oh man
top-3 obviously love and basketball so
it was important the best man I only
have like one solid alright movie yes
alright let's do this oh my god Ricky
done [ __ ] that's what I'm sure it wasn't
poison oh that's what it is
hello Alicia oh my god remember it write
it down create cream broccoli sure come
on this is Friday Friday if you're black
I have never seen Friday I'm gonna take
away your black card oh my god what is
the name of this movie Friday oh my god
this is Friday this is Friday Jesus
Christ are you kidding me I'm so mad at
myself
somebody come in here clean this [ __ ] up
please oh my god okay okay
Tina Turner I can't eat right Tina
Turner I guess what does it call isn't
it the name of the movie I can Tina
what's love got to do with it give me
that point I thought the gift if I can
turn out what's love got to do with it I
think it's the color purple anime who is
anime I don't know what don't be a
minute
I'm gonna say the color head I'm wrong
yeah get competitive now that's sweat on
my forehead
[Music]
you make me finish the time a baby boy
right now baby boy maybe would I want a
second off my way who's that talking
right now
taraji baby boy baby boy what I would
kiss on all you [ __ ] okay Denzel
thank you so much I know this is oh he's
got a thousand movies I'm assuming this
training day any day Trinidad is it paid
in full training day I did it was a lot
of fun always I could do it more and I
think black film is important obviously
because of representation we are already
misrepresented in the media and I think
having black films you can see yourself
in different lights for me the movies
that resonated with me the most that are
the movies that have people that look
like me talk like me act like me I guess
I'll walk out of here with my black card
intact and keep being unapologetically
black
[Music]